my dear brothers and sisters may Allah
bless you all we've made a video
concerning the issue of advising sisters
to look after their husbands and I just
want to mention something about divorce
and Islam divorce is allowed it's
permissible
and sometimes divorce happens not
because the husband is evil or the wife
is evil or the husband the husband is a
bad person or the wife is a bad person
sometimes just they don't get along
anymore and the best thing is to live in
peace well
experienced that sometimes sister goes
after she gets divorced
by husband she goes exposing his uh
personal issues likewise the husbands
start backbiting her and exposing her
personal issues that is not permissible
in Islam
so if you divorce maybe you know bless
you with a righteous husband as for the
the husband bless him with the righteous
wife as for exposing your personal uh
issues to the whole world then that is
not permissible from Islam